Let's go ahead and give our student
user access to pseudo themselves.
I'll first copy the vagrant file and
name it student.
I'll then need to make
a small edit to this file and
I'll just use nano to do that.
This second line here is actually
what's doing all of the work.
The file name doesn't mean anything,
so we'll change the word
vagrant here to student.
There are a few more options here.
And if you'd like to
understand them all,
I've placed a link in the instructor
notes for more information.
For now, we just want student users
pseudo access to function exactly as
the vagrant users currently does.
After saving that file, I've switched
back to my terminal where I'm logged in
as the student and we'll try to
run this pseudo command again.
And there we go, we see the results.
Our student user now has
access to use pseudo.